REPUBLICANS IN THIS, STATE ARE
REALLY RESPONDING.
ESPECIALLY THE ONES WHO LED
THAT CHARGE AGAINST KARI LAKE.
BECAUSE THERE IT IS AND
DEPENDENTS.
AND MODERATE PUBLICANS, LOVE
SOUNDLY REJECTED HER.
OR TO SHOW YOU THIS QUOTE FROM
ONE OF THOSE REPUBLICANS.
JOHN GRAHAM, WHO IS A
REPUBLICAN WHO FUNDRAISED FOR
KATIE HOBBS.
I'D LIKE TO REPUBLICAN.
WHO SAID HE SIMPLY COULD NOT
STOMACH HER INDECENCY.
HE TELLS CNN, QUOTE,.
CIVILITY HAS WON HERE IN
ARIZONA.
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I ALSO HEARD, FROM A NUMBER OF
OTHER REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
WORK ON CAMPAIGNS.
WHO STRATEGIZE, WHO COMMUNICATE
FOR REPUBLICANS IN THE STATE.
ONE TOLD ME, ON BACKGROUND,
BECAUSE HE IS ACTIVELY WORKING
ON CAMPAIGN SAILOR ARIZONA.
HE SAID, QUOTE, KARI LAKE TOLD
A LEGION OF JOHN MCCAIN
SUPPORTERS ACROSS ARIZONA THAT
THEY COULD GO TO.
TONIGHT, THEY RETURNED THE
FAVOR.
AND WHAT HE'S TALKING ABOUT
THEIR, NORAH, IS A MOMENT WHERE
KARI LAKE AND CPAC SAID THAT
HER PRIMARY VICTORY TOLD --
AND SHE EXPRESSES THIS TO THE
ENTIRE CROWD.
SHE SAID THAT HER CAMPAIGN
DROVE A STAKE IN THE HEART OF
THE MCCAIN MACHINE.
THIS WAS THE MCCAIN SHEEN
STRIKING BACK.
>> CAN, POWERFUL WORDS.
AND APPARENTLY, AS YOU, SAY
RETURNING THE FAVOR.
HERE TO DISCUSS ALL THIS RIGHT
NOW.
CHIEF POLITICAL ANALYST HERE AT
CNN, OR A FORGER.
CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATOR,
CHARLIE DENT, AND ASHLEY
ALLISON.
FIRST OF ALL, WE THINK ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE IN THE MONDAY AFTER THE
MIDTERM ELECTION.
WE ARE STILL WAITING TO SEE WHO
FINALLY WILL ACTUALLY BE THE
MAJORITY PARTY IN THE HOUSE.
NOW WE KNOW WHO THE NEXT
GOVERNOR WILL BE.
JUST THINK ABOUT THIS.
TODAY, LIZ CHENEY IS PUTTING
OUT YOUR WELCOME KARI LAKE.
THIS IS SOMETHING, THIS WAS A
LOT OF ENERGY.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> MY REACTION IS THAT SOMEBODY
WOULD LIKE TO CALL OR PUNISH
CHEATERS AND CROOKS.
WHO TOLD JOHN MCCAIN SUPPORTERS
TO LEAVE, AND WALK OUT THE
DOOR.
AFTER JOHN MCCAIN MORE THAN
THREE DECADES OF DEVOTION TO
PUBLIC SERVICE.
WHO CAMPAIGNED AS DONALD
TRUMP'S MINI ME.
WAS SENT WALKING.
BECAUSE THAT WAS NOT WHAT
ARIZONA MODERATES, ARIZONA
INDEPENDENTS, OR ARIZONA
REPUBLICANS WANTED.
AND I THINK SHE MADE A REALLY
BAD BET, IN THE STATE OF
ARIZONA.
I THINK REPUBLICANS ARE GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT THIS IN THE
STATE.
AS CONGRESS JUST SAYING.
AND SAYING, WHAT DID WE DO
WRONG?
HOW DID WE NOMINATE THIS PERSON?
HOW DO WE FIX THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
DEMOCRATS WIN ANOTHER CRITICAL
MIDTERM BATTLEGROUND.
WE SEE THE SAD AND PREDICTABLE
REACTION FROM THE ELECTION
DENIER WHO LOST.
KATIE HOBBS WILL SERVE AS
ARIZONA'S FIFTH FEMALE GOVERNOR,
RIGHT HERE, ARIZONA.
HER WIN FLIPS THE GOVERNOR'S
MANSION THERE TO BLUE AND IT
DEALS A LOSS TO THE ARE
REPUBLICAN AND TRUMP AK LITE
KARI LAKE, THE TV ANCHOR WHO
TRANSFORMED INTO A CONSPIRACY
HOUSE.
LAKE'S REACTION EXPECTED AND
SAD, EGREGIOUS.
ARIZONIANS KNOW BS WHEN THEY SEE
IT, SHE TWEETED.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, MATH IS MATH.
THE NUMBERS UNLIKE ELECTION
DENIERS DO NOT LIE.
KARI LAKE TRAILING 49.6, KATIE
HOBBS, 50.4.
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
WE MADE THE PROJECTION LAST
NIGHT AFTER NEW VOTES CAME IN IN
MARICOPA COUNTY.
IN THE LAST INSTALLMENT FROM
MARICOPA COUNTY KARI LAKE CAME
OUT ON TOP BUT WAS WELL BENEATH
THE MARGIN SHE NEEDED TO CATCH .
KATIE HOBBS AHEAD, SMALL BATCHES
OF VOTES CAME IN FROM AROUND THE
COUNTY SURROUNDING THE STATE
TOO.
KATIE HOBBS, KATIE HOBBS WILL BE
THE NEXT GOVERNOR OF ARIZONA.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
KATIE HOBBS, THE SECRETARY OF
STATE IN 2020 WHO SAID, NO,
DONALD TRUMP YOU LOST.
JOE BIDEN WON, WILL NOW BE
GOVERNOR, DEFEATING THE WOMAN
WHO STOOD BY DONALD TRUMP, WHO
.
OUTSIDE OF BATTLEGROUND ARIZONA,
LOOK WHAT DEMOCRATS DID.
DEMOCRATS LOST THE NEVADA
GOVERNORSHIP.
THAW WIN IN ARIZONA.
THEY HOLD, WISCONSIN, MICHIGAN,
AND PENNSYLVANIA.
THEY PICK UP MASSACHUSETTS, THEY
PICK UP MARYLAND.
THEY HOLD KANSAS AND COLORADO.
THEY HOLD OREGON AS WELL.
DEMOCRATS LOOKING AT THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE AND SAYING WE
HAVE BUILT A BENCH FOR THE
FUTURE.
KARI LAKE SAYING EVEN BEFORE WE
MADE THE PROJECTION LAST NIGHT,
THIS IS NOT OVER.
SOMEHOW I MUST HAVE BEEN
CHEATED.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE
OF ARIZONA WOULD VOTE FOR HER
AND THAT SHE WOULD WIN, BUT IF
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS AT THE END
OF THE DAY, HOW DO YOU CERTIFY
AN ELECTION THAT IS THIS
BOTCHED, AND SHE'S THE ONE THAT
WOULD CERTIFY HER OWN ELECTION
WHERE IT WAS BOTCHED WHERE THE
MACHINES DIDN'T WORK IN MORE
THAN A THIRD OF THE POLLING
CENTERS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE REMEDY THIS,
BUT THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA ARE
FURIOUS.
THEY'RE REACHING OUT TO US BY
THE THOUSANDS SAYING I DON'T
THINK MY VOTE EVEN WAS COUNTED.
>> WITH ME IN STUDIO TO SHARE
THEIR REPORTING AND INSIGHTS,
JACKIE KA SEN ITCH OF THE DAILY
BEECH, AND TIA MITCHELL.
KARI LAKE SAYS ARIZONIANS KNOW
BS WHEN THEY SEE IT.
NO, ARIZONIANS KNOW MATH, TOUGH
MATH, COMPETITIVE RACE, VERY
CLOSE RACE JUST LIKE THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL RACE WAS, BUT KATIE
HOBBS IS THE NEXT GOVERNOR.
THE QUESTION IS KARI LAKE HAS
EVERY RIGHT, WAIT UNTIL 100% OF
THE VOTE IS COUNTED.
WAIT UNTIL IT IS CERTIFIED AS
OFFICIAL.
IF YOU SEE SOMETHING YOU WANT TO
HAVE A RECOUNT OR A CANVAS, THAT
IS WITHIN THE RIGHT OF ANY
CANDIDATES, BUT THEN WHAT?
WILL SHE STICK TO THIS OR MOVE
ON?
>> WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH OTHER
ELECTION DENIERS THROW THE LAST
COUPLE OF DAYS IS THEY HAVE
CONCEDED.
IT MAY HAVE TAKEN A COUPLE OF
DAYS.
IT MAY HAVE GRUDGINGLY, BUT
THERE HAVE BEEN CONCESSIONS
BECAUSE THEY ALL LOST.
THE ELECTION DENIERS, THE PEOPLE
THAT REALLY CLOSELY AFFILIATED
THEMSELVES WITH DONALD TRUMP'S
MISINFORMATION LOST ACROSS THE
BOARD, BUT, YOU KNOW, WE'LL HAVE
TO SEE IF EVENTUALLY SHE
CONCEDES.
SHE CERTAINLY DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
SHE'S HEAD THERE HAD.
>> DOUG MASTRIANO, WHO CONCEDED,
I THINK IT WAS LIKE THE MORNING
OF HIS CONCESSION, HE WAS STILL
RE-TWEETING CLAIMS OF ELECTION
FRAUD FOR WHICH THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE.
I THINK THE BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE CONCESSIONS OF SOME
OF THESE CANDIDATES VERSUS
DONALD TRUMP'S CONTINUED
ELECTION LIES ABOUT THE 2020
ELECTION IS TRUMP HAD FAR MORE
POWER, FAR MORE INFLUENCE OVER
THE PROCESS THAN ANY OF THESE
CANDIDATES DO.
AS MUCH AS KARI LAKE WOULD LIKE
TO PERHAPS CONTINUE DENYING THE
RESULT OF THE ELECTION, HER
ABILITY TO ACTUALLY CHANGE THOSE
RESULTS OR TO TRY AND INFLUENCE
IT THROUGH SOME KIND OF JANUARY
6th MOMENT IS LIMITED.
>> THE QUESTION IS DOES KARI
LAKE WANT TO RUN AGAIN?
WHAT DOES SHE THINK THE BEST
STRATEGY IS IF SHE WANTS TO HAVE
A FUTURE IN POLITICS.
WE SAW ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
WHETHER IT'S MASTRIANO IN
PENNSYLVANIA, MAGGIE HASSAN SAYS
TODAY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
REPUBLICANS SHOULD TAKE NOTE.
ELECTION DENYING DOESN'T WORK.
>> I THINK THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
RESOUNDEDLY REJECTED ELECTION
DENIERS.
THEY KNOW HOW DANGEROUS IT IS.
I THINK WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
CHANGING OUR CAMPAIGN FINANCE
SYSTEM, AND I THINK WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW THAT
ELECTION DENIAL IS NOT SPOUPPORD
BY VOTERS.
PEOPLE KNOW HOW DANGEROUS IT IS.
>> VOTERS SEEM TO HAVE AGREED
WITH THAT THAT IN MOST -- NOT
ALL, BUT IN MOST CASES,
ESPECIALLY THE BIG HIGH PROFILE
RACES FOR KBRGOVERNOR AND SECREY
OF STATE, THE QUESTION IS DOES
KARI LAKE GET THAT MESSAGE?
>> YEAH, I THINK IT'S BECAUSE SO
MANY OF THESE ELECTION
DENIERS -- AND YOU KNOW, BEING
PERCEIVED AS ERODING DEMOCRACY
DID NOT HELP, BUT A LOT OF THEM,
THAT DENIALISM WAS VERY MUCH
THEIR BRAND AS A CANDIDATE.
THEY DIDN'T SEEM TO BRING MUCH
ELSE TO THE TABLE WHEN IT CAME
TO ACTUALLY POLICY, POLICY
ISSUES THAT AMERICAN VOTERS, YOU
KNOW, WANT THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS, PARTICULARLY IN THESE
GOVERNORS' MANSIONS TO ADDRESS.
AND SO TO ME THAT'S A LESSON TOO
IS LIKE YOU CAN'T JUST BE ONE
NOTE, ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
ECONOMY AND OTHER POLICY ISSUES
ARE AT THE TOP OF MINDS OF
VOTERS.
>> SO THE DEMOCRATS HELD THE
SENATE RACE IN GEORGIA TO SEE
NEXT MONTH, TO SEE WHETHER THEY
CAN GET 51, WHICH WOULD BE A
MAJORITY FROM THE COMMITTEES,
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THEM TO DO A
LOT MORE.
THIS IS VERY SIGNIFICANT WHEN
YOU LOOK TO THE FUTURE.
LOOK AT THESE GOVERNOR'S RACES.
JARED POLIS HELD ON IN COLORADO,
GRETCHEN W
GRETCHEN WHITMER HELD ON IN
MICHIGAN, THE DEMOCRAT REELECTED
IN KANSAS.
TWO DEMOCRATS REPLACING RETIRING
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS IN
MASSACHUSETTS AND MARYLAND.
THOSE REPUBLICAN KCANDIDATES IN
THOSE RACES WERE TRUMP ELECTION
DENIERS.
>> RIGHT, AND THAT'S, AGAIN, ONE
OF THE REASONS -- SOMETHING LIKE
THE JOSH SHAPIRO RACE, THAT
WASN'T EVEN REMOTELY CLOSE.
IT WAS JUST, YOU KNOW, A
LANDSLIDE.
SIMILARLY, MICHIGAN WASN'T THE
RACE THAT I THINK SOME PEOPLE
THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE BECAUSE OF
SOME OF THE DISSATISFACTION WITH
GOVERNOR WHITMER.
AND ALL OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE
THE -- THAT WERE THE ELECTION
DENIERS WERE THE CANDIDATES OF
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THERE WERE OTHER CANDIDATES.
THERE WERE OTHER CANDIDATE THAT
RAN AGAINST THESE FOLKS WHO MAY
HAVE DONE BETTER.
WE'LL NEVER KNOW, BUT THAT
WARRING WAS OVER IN THE PRIMARY,
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE LEFT
WITH.